-It's always a joy
to see both of you.
Thank you for being here
on our Fallontine's Day show.
When I think of a bromance,
I think of you guys.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-We appreciate that.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You guys have been friends
for nearly 40 years.
-Yeah.
-We talked about this
on the show.
You were in detention
in grade school.
[ Laughter ]
Here you are in seventh grade.
Look at this.
[ Awws ]
-So studious.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What is the secret to such
a long-lasting friendship?
Have you ever had fights
or conflicts?
-Well, we're actually --
We're kind of going through
something right now,
to be honest with you,
[ Laughter ]
because Link, in a mountain,
biking accident
broke his collarbone
in December,
so, he's basically fully
recovered, but he wore a sling.
-Yeah, I was wearing a sling
for like
the whole month of January
on the show.
-Right. And what I realized,
at the time --
and this is the source
of the conflict --
is that, when I get excited
about something that's happening
on the show --
and, of course,
we sit as Rhett & Link,
so nobody gets confused, just
like we're doing right now --
[ Laughter ]
I'll hit him in the shoulder.
I'm, "Hey!" You know,
I'm having a good time.
I'm punching my buddy, you know?
-Yes.
-And I realized I actually --
I hit him quite a lot.
[ Laughter ]
-And he had his --
And you were wearing a sling.
-Yeah.
-Guy's got a broken collarbone.
-So, I've been trying to find
like a new approach
to like connect, you know.
-See, your reaction's
getting better.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I mean, you're getting
really good.
[ Laughter ]
-Now that I've gotten rid
of the sling,
I've finally gotten good at it.
-Like a wax on/wax off type
of thing.
-Yeah, but I haven't really
landed on anything
because this feels
a little bit weird.
-Yeah, don't do that.
-You said you got a little kind
of testy, having this sling.
-I did, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I got a little antsy.
I wanted to get out of it.
Actually, I'd planned, like
the last day I had to wear it,
we were shooting
"Good Mythical Morning"
and I said, "I'm just going
to Hulk out of this thing.
I'm not going to tell Rhett
about it.
It's going to be
a big surprise.
It's going to be just this
huge moment for our audience
and for Rhett,
for me to just break out!"
-Yeah.
-But it didn't --
It wasn't as easy
as I thought it was going to be.
[ Laughter ]
-It wasn't as smooth
as that, no.
I want to show you.
Here's Link trying
to Hulk out of his sling.
Check this out.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Breathing deeply ]
Aaaaaaaaaaaaah!
[ Laughter ]
Aah!
Aaaaaaaaaaaaah!
Aah! Aah! Aaaah!
[ Laughter ]
Aah!
Aaaaaaah!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Your reaction.
-Hey, listen, if he's anything,
he's subtle.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. You're currently
in Season 23
of "Good Mythical Morning."
-Thank you.
-You have 11 billion views
across all channels.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Crazy.
-Congratulations.
You have a new new thing
that you've been doing,
that is almost like a talent
that you think that you have.
-Yes.
-A special talent.
-Actually, today's episode
of "GMM"...
-It just dropped.
-...we brought out
a panel of people
and we said that we could
identify best friends.
You know, I mean, because we've
been best friends so long,
we can, you know, we spot them.
[ Snapping fingers ]
Almost instantaneous.
-And it turns out
we actually could not.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, we failed
in every single opportunity
and so we thought maybe tonight
we could have a chance
at redemption
and you could join us and see
if you're any better than us
at spotting best friends.
-Alright.
-Look in the audience.
-So can we go in the audience
and see two people?
Just find two people, random.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Alright, alright,
now don't say.
Alright, alright.
Alright, now,
what do we have to do?
We have to decide
if they're strangers,
best friends, or friends?
-They could be lovers, you know.
[ Laughter ]
-We don't know.
-It's Valentine's Day.
-Do you have
to ask them questions?
-Yeah.
-Well, could you guys
just kind of
make eye contact
with one another?
-I don't know.
They can't really do it.
-Okay, they're very smiley,
giggly.
Okay, if you were coming back
from a long trip
and you were greeting
one another,
how would you greet one another?
Just, you know, physically.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah, they're definitely
best friends.
[ Laughter ]
It's written all
over their faces.
-I would say that I'm not sure.
I'm not sure they know
each other.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-They are not even acquainted.
-You think? These people did not
know each other until tonight.
-At all.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what I'm saying.
-Is that true?
-What about you?
-Yep.
-We do know each other.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, act like it!
-Is everything okay?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Alright, let's try again.
Look.
You didn't redeem yourself.
-Okay.
Give us another chance.
-Let's find two other people
and see if we can try
this again.
Where else can the camera go?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Those guys?
-Here we go. Yeah.
-Okay.
Okay. There kind of matching,
in an odd way.
-Can we see, you know,
your secret handshake?
[ Laughter ]
-We don't have one.
-Make one up.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Not bad.
-That was a good
secret handshake.
It's good. It's so secret,
they don't even know it.
[ Laughter ]
-How would you guys
greet one another,
if you had been apart
from each other for, you know,
hadn't seen each other in a year
and you're reunited,
you see each other after a year.
How would you embrace?
-[ Scoffs ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-I say --
I say they're
-Strangers!
-strangers. Strangers!
-Never met.
-Never met. Never met.
Will never talk again.
[ Laughter ]
Never speak another word
to each other.
-I think you might
redeem yourselves.
What do you think?
Do they know each other?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
I think they might be
in a relationship.
-Alright.
Are you guys in a relationship?
-Yes.
-Yes!
-We just got engaged.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, my!
[ Rimshot ]
-Happy Fallontine's Day!
The very talented Rhett & Link.
Congratulations.
All episodes
of "Good Mythical Morning"
are available on YouTube.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show."
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ The Roots playing funk ]
-♪ Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh,
uh-huh, uh-huh ♪